oh I hope you guys appreciate what I do
for you this is the Princess Diaries if
you couldn't guess I didn't see this
when I came out in theatres but it's
Disney's embers so it was kind of hoping
maybe this would be that little surprise
that caught me off guard and it's not
alright let's look at the story and
Hathaway is a really nerdy girl who just
wants to disappear and be invisible but
suddenly her grandmother who never
visits played by Julie Andrews comes in
and reveals that in fact she is a queen
and that through some complicated
bloodline and Hathaway is in fact a
princess and that by blood she's the
only one who can take over ruling at the
way of course doesn't want the position
and just wants to disappear but Julie
Andrews thinks that the more she can
talk to her in the more that she can
convince her the more she'll come around
to taking the post or else it's going to
be handed over to an evil guy who wants
to do bad things with it probably I
don't know we never exactly figured out
his politics but he looks bad so I'm
sure it's gonna be bad
what follows is of course every cliche
you can think of in this set up the
scenes where they have to act all
elegant and she screws up the visual
jokes the scenes where she has to act
like she's princessy but Oh slap stick
is gonna happen the kid and the
grandmother aren't gonna get along but
over time they will learn from one
another and they'll find out all sorts
of neat things and just when you think
they're gonna get along all of a sudden
something happens to throw a wrench into
the works and they think they hate each
other but then of course they come
around and oh you've heard that story
before don't worry there's about a
million other cliches you've heard
before including the idiot bad boy she
wants to date even though there's a
perfectly good boy that wants to date
her but of course she doesn't realize it
the nerdy best friend that of course
she's gonna betray the bully that never
says anything real bullies do or does
anything real police do the goof-up
she's gonna have that somehow don't
really goof up anything and everyone's
still happy when she takes the position
I think the only thing missing is the
actual political talk yeah if she's got
a rule a kingdom shouldn't she you know
know about the kingdom and shouldn't she
know about politics shouldn't she be
thrust into this no it's more important
to have her wave properly or wear the
correct dresses and
sheesh the director of this movie is
Gary Marshall who I've seen in
interviews and is a great producer I'm
sure is very nice but god I don't think
I've seen one movie from him that I've
liked
he kind of does for the female audience
what say Vin Diesel does for the male
audience yeah we know it's stupid and
it's really bad but we kind of give it a
pass cuz hey would it be cool if we were
in that situation well I don't like a
lot of in diesel films and I don't like
a lot of these films either the formula
is beyond tired and beyond predictable
you can guess every single moment that's
going to happen as I was watching it I
was pleading pleading for it to give me
something new something I haven't seen
before something that makes it unique
and I guess if you want to get kind of
specific there is one thing that sort of
makes it unique and that's the
performances the majority of actors in
this movie are trying their hardest to
give a role that you haven't seen before
even though the role has been written
millions of times and to the credit some
of them kind of work like Julie Andrews
does give her own very unique charm to
the whole thing while the role is not
written well at all she does in fact
give it this certain dignity every
single time she talks you know that not
only is she trying to connect with her
daughter but she's trying to be a
politician she's trying to balance
everything out and you hear the
desperation in her voice to get this
done so I think she works out really
well I never quite got on the heat and
had the weibo like a lot of our people
did I just never thought you'd pick very
good movies but as the nerdy girl she
does okay and as the pretty girl she
does okay there probably could have been
an actress that could bring more to it
but at the same time she has nothing to
work with and for what she did I think
it's pretty impressive
there's a head of security character we
seen a million times but again he does
pretty well there's a hair designer
we've seen a million times but again
this guy's acting is actually very funny
but even with all these people trying
their hardest they just can't make do
with a story that is so damn recycled
and tropes that have been drilled into
the ground and those goddamn musical
moments where you just want to go oh how
inspiring how whimsical I just want to
puke all over the damn screen on a
pretty little dress I guess if you're
looking for a movie that is just the
straightforward Cinderella story and you
want to pretend yourself as the pretty
girl being made up
it's still kind of bad but if you're
just going in for pure fantasy and your
unbelievably forgiving I guess this film
is for you anyone else I say this is a
diary you can definitely skip
you